The One Piece Manga has just revealed Vegapunk’s
dream to create free limitless energy for
the entire world, and dropped a major hint
that this lost ancient technology is directly
connected to devil fruits.
And speaking of devil fruits from a long time
ago, for the first time after 10 years, we
see Rob Lucci in his Zoan Leopard form encountering
his nemesis Luffy.
As it turns out these two things are actually
directly connected to each other.
Vegapunk’s dream and research about the
limitless energy source are the main reason
that Imu and the Gorosei have ordered his
assassination and ordered CP0 to Egghead island.
We already speculated that the government
was after Vegapunk because of his knowledge
of ancient technology from the ancient kingdom.
By the way, this is something that’s always
bugged me a little bit, because the name ‘ancient
kingdom is actually a mistranslation’.
In the original Japanese, it’s actually
called ‘巨大な王国’ which translated
means ‘The gigantic kingdom’ not the ancient
kingdom.
Which I’ve always thought gives the name
a totally different vibe.
Ancient sounds pretty cool too, but gigantic
makes it sound even more impressive and global
than ancient i would say.
The Wiki has corrected this to ‘the great
kingdom’, but again kyodai means enormous
or gigantic, which is again completely different
from great.
And it’s not only the adjective that’s
wrong, I think the translation ‘ancient
kingdom’ has created the impression amongst
western fans, that the ancient weapons are
part of the ancient kingdom, something that
we actually don’t know for a fact.
They could have been weapons owned BY Joy
Boy, but it’s also possible that the ancient
weapons were created by someone else much
earlier and they could even turn out to be
what destroyed the kingdom in the first place.
Which would explain why Imu uses what could
be to be uranus.
I’m not sure if this translation mistake
was made because both the gigantic kingdom
and the ancient weapons date back from the
void century or because Kyodai, gigantic,
and kodai, ancient’ sound so similar.
Sorry for that little rant.
I do think it’s important though.
Because Vegapunk uses Kodai in this chapter
to describe the ancient energy and the ancient
machine soldier.
Kodai enerugi and kodai kikaihei.
I don’t know about you, but to me that sounds
a lot like this ancient robot, as well as
the three ancient weapons were all powered
by this unlimited ancient energy, that Vegapunk
is looking for.
Those three actually do share a naming scheme,
unlike the gigantic kingdom.
And i do believe that this mysterious ancient
energy is connected to the power of devil
Vegapunk’s dream to create limitless free
energy for the world is actually inspired
by another famous inventor.
While Vegapunk is already inspired by Einstein
look-wise and has the apple on his head as
a nod to Newton, his dream is that of Nicola
Tesla, the man who revolutionized technology
and basically laid the foundation for our
modern technologically advanced civilization.
In case you don’t know, just like Vegapunk,
Tesla also dreamt of a world where unlimited
energy could be wirelessly made accessible
to all.
To create a better world for people and end
the toxic side effect of fossil fuels for
both humans and the planet.
One of Tesla’s most extraordinary experiments
in this regard was to transmit electrical
power over long distances without wires or
cables.
He planned on building a giant tower using
this technology that would be able to spread
free electricity around the world.
His investor at the time, J.P. Morgan, pulled
all his money from Tesla as a result.
He owned companies making everything from
cables to phone polls to fossil fuel generators.
He had absolutely no interest in financing
a project that could result in free electricity.
Was Tesla’s technology real?
Well he did invent a ton of stuff that worked.
And it is said that the US Government confiscated
most of his research after his death.
So we might never know if it was real or not.
What’s important for us, is that the parallels
to One PIece are clear as day.
The world government, just like the US government
allegedly would have no interest whatsoever
in free unlimited energy for the entire planet.
The Gorosei have worked hard to keep the people
of the world stuck in the 17 hundreds technologically,
which makes the world easier to control for
them.
Vegapunk is trying to re-discover this energy
from its use during the void century, similar
to how Nicola Tesla was said to believe that
the great pyramids of Egypt were actually
ancient power plants that created clean unlimited
energy.
I personally am very much fascinated by Tesla
and his work, which has been getting a lot
more attention again in recent years.
And I think he is a great inspiration for
Vegapunk’s character.
However, you might be surprised that this
is not only true in a positive, but also in
a very negative way.
It’s pretty much undeniable that Nico Tesla
was one of the brightest thinkers, if not
the brightest in modern human history, just
like Vegapunk in One PIece.
However, as a person he was far from a great
guy.
Not only was he said to be incredibly antisocial
and delusional, but he was also a big believer
in Eugenics, basically Nazi philosophy, convinced
that certain types of people should be systematically
eliminated. he wrote that in 1935 by the way.
Bad timing.
And as I’ve talked about before in other
videos, Vegapunk shares this much darker side
to his character too.
Yes he has good ideals and wants to end wars,
which is why he gets along great with Dragon
and comes off as a good guy, but he also has
been conducting inhuman and ethically terrible
experiments on humans and other life forms.
The cover story with Ceasar and Judge Vinsmoke
thinking of their former glory days just drives
this point home even more.
Think of Sanji and his siblings, the kids
on Punk Hazard, Gas weapons and all the military
assets that Vegapunk has created for the government,
including the Seraphim, that now literally
have come to take him out in this chapter.
Vegapunk has good ideals, but doesn’t mind
doing bad things in the name of scientific
progress.
I’m actually very curious what direction
Oda will take his character in and if this
will become a major plot point or not.
Because Oda has made it a point to show us
both sides of the genius doctor.
But let’s get back to the ancient energy
and devil fruits.
If there used to be unlimited power during
the void century, it explains how a technologically
advanced civilisation was able to reshape
the entire planet and how a war on this level
could trow society back 500 years.
I already mentioned that the ancient weapons
and the ancient mechanic soldier were clearly
powered by this energy.
Which also means that 200 years ago, when
the Robot attacked Marijois, someone had access
to this energy.
So what could it be?
There is actually one more example of ancient
technology, that uses large amounts of energy.
The hidden city on the moon that enel discovered.
The remains of the technologically advanced
sky people, who ran out of resources and thus
came to earth.
Maybe this was their attempt at fixing their
ressource problem.
It might also be the answer to why Vegapunk
is specifically talking about ending wars
for resources, because so far we haven’t
really seen that be an issue in One PIece
so far.
But anyways, this ancient city on the moon
is reactivated by Enels electricity powers.
Now I have speculated about this mysterious
ancient power source before.
it could be a form of nuclear fusion, same
as in the sun, which would fit with Luffy
and his sun god fruit.
Luffy bringing the dawn could also mean bringing
light in the form of unlimited energy.
Which i still like a lot.
But it could also be that Enel and his fruit
are much more important than expected.
Maybe the man with the god complex really
has the power of a god.
After all he is able to generate pretty much
unlimited electricity on a ridiculous scale.
He was able to power the city up with a single
move.
The goro goro no mi might well be this source
of infinite energy that Vegapunk is looking
for.
Or, it could also be that devil fruits themselves
are powered by this infinite energy, which
allows them to create their powers.
If devil fruits are actually a technology
and not magic, then the energy for Aokiji
to freeze an entire ocean or Akainu to melt,
must come from somewhere.
An infinite energy source powering each fruit
would explain this.
Which would make Devil Fruits advanced biotechnology.
Again not that unreasonable an assumption
when you think about Vegapunks scientific
research of them.
One crucial and incredibly fascinating thing
that Vegapunk’s research revealed, is that
being subscribed to my channel will get you
more and better one piece content every single
week.
But speaking of the power of devil fruits
and research on them, we of course have to
talk about the arrival of Lucci and the Seraphim
on the island.
It looks like all of the Seraphim have not
only lunarian dna, Kizaru’s light powers
and superhuman strength, but also a devil
fruit.
Since Kuma’s seraphim has his fruit’s
power, I’m going to assume that warloards
with a devil fruit power will have their devil
fruit as well.
So seraphim crocodile will have a sand logia,
moria will have shadow powers and doflamingo
string powers.
Meanwhile, it seems like Seraphim of people
who have no fruit, get one that works perfectly
with their power.
Jinbei’s version has the swim swim fruit
to work with his fishman karate for instance.
We have also learned that the Seraphim have
codenames relating to each warloards animal
theme.
in case you don’t know, each of the original
7 warloards has some sort of animal reference.
The 4 that are on Egghead island right now
are Kuma’s Seraphim, S-bear, since Kuma
means bear in Japanese.
S-snake must be Boa hancock’s, S-shark is
Jinbei, which means whaleshark in japanese
and S-hawk is of course Mihawk.
And boy for Mihawk i cant wait to see what
fruit Oda gave him to complement his sword
fighting abilities.
That’s gonna be ridiculously overpowered.
At the moment, one Seraphim is fighting wiht
CP0, while Vegapunk has given control of the
other 3 to Sentomaru, the sumo guy from Sabaody
arcapelago.
He’s not only the first person to use advanced
armament haki in One Piece, but also Vegapunks
personal guard assigned by the marines.
Now, Cypher pole is not part of the Marines,
but im still curious to see if Sentomaro will
actually fight for Vegapunk or will betray
him, which would mean that the straw hats
would have to face 4 of the seraphim, which
does sound a lot more fair to be honest.
If a fight were to happen, I’m also curious
who Stussy and Kaku would fight.
Chopper and Jinbei, because they are with
Luffy?
But this of course purely depends on whether
or not Lucci is actually foolish enough to
pick a fight with Luffy.
Like, dont get me wrong, I do hope and expect
that Lucci has grown a lot stronger over the
time skip.
But it would make absolutley no sense that
he’s as strong or stronger than Kaido.
A leopard is definitley weaker than a dragon,
even if Lucci is awakened at this point.
If anything there should be more parallels
here with Who’s who, who also is a fromer
cp9 memeber who ate a cat type devil fruit.
I was also happy to see that Lucci used his
rokushiki techniques against Atlas here.
I’m probably not the only one, who felt
like these techniques became a bit useless
after the introduction of Haki.
But it looks like Oda is determined to show
that these powers are actually still important
and useful in the stroy.
Now, if Lucci actually fights Luffy and Luffy
takes a few hits next chapter or so, i just
want you to rememeber that luffy barely goes
all out right from the start.
I can totally see him taking a few hits from
Lucci before he finishes him off quickly.
But who knows, maybe it’s actually going
to be Kuma who will fight Lucci.
After all the real kuma is also coming to
Egghead right now.
And just to throw it out there, it would be
kind of sick if Kuma would send Luffy somewhere
again this time around.
And I’m sure Vegapunk still has a lot of
tricks up his sleeve to.
Especially with his devil fruit power, that
i discussed in a lot of detail in last chapter’s
review right here.
Go check that out if you like.